[Music]
welcome everybody we're
opening the zoom room a couple moments
early just to let y'all
enter the space we have a pretty big
audience today
a really exciting topic we are joined by
some
amazing folks so welcome my name is will
torres i'm one of the admission officers
here at the stanford graduate school of
business
today we are going to be talking about
how do you prepare for
a career in entrepreneurship what are
some of the resources
tips and things to keep an eye out while
you're at the gsb
let's go ahead and get to our panelists
if we can go from left
to right so um john pierre
please introduce yourself and tell us a
little bit about uh what you're doing
what you're doing these days hi everyone
my name is jean-pierre
i also go by jp for short i'm originally
from florida prince haiti
and i've been living in the us for about
10 years now
so i just finished my first year at gsd
and over the summer i'm actually doing
what's called the both the chin
fellowship it's a fellowship
whereby students are giving a stipend
and they're encouraged to explore
any space or business idea that they're
interested in and hopes that i could
find something that would focus on
entirely their second year and i'm
currently in new york visiting family
but tomorrow i'll actually fly back to
palo alto so i'll be
near the stanford campus for the entire
summer and i'm super excited to be here
with all of you today
nice um jp john pierre um
did you know you wanted to go into
entrepreneurship coming into business
school
yeah i actually did so for me it was one
of my main goals of going to business
school and it's something i'd thought of
uh really ever since i was in undergrad
uh for a number of reasons
i think primarily because i grew up in a
family that's
pretty entrepreneurial even though at
you know the very low scale of things so
for example
my grandparents growing up they were
both self-employed
uh so my grandfather for example he was
a tailor my grandmother at a
small shop in her local neighborhood my
parents similar situation my father is
self-employed he's an electrical
engineer
where he does installations for local
customers and my
mother has a kindergarten where she
enrolls
kids and essentially ensures their
education for
their first few years so i've always
been around people who have
been very independent so for me it was
always a goal
and i just wanted to make sure i could
go to a place
where i would be able to give an edge to
my career so i could make the most of it
nice thanks for joining us today erin
could you tell us a little bit about
what you're doing these days
yeah thanks will so i am i graduated
last year from the gsd
uh in the middle of the pandemic as you
know it sounds like
yaniv is doing himself this year uh or
at least at the tail end
but uh these days i am the co-founder
and uh head of growth at the mental
health
technology company called prairie health
so i
founded this with a couple other folks
from stanford who i met while
at the gsb they are not the gsb
themselves and we got started just
before the start of the pandemic
and ended up launching with our first
customers
uh the week of graduation last year so
it's been
about a year now uh that we've been live
and uh
very excited by the work we've been able
to do over that over the course of that
last year
nice and then aaron did you know you
wanted to go into entrepreneurship
coming into business school
yes and no it wasn't as clear as jp i'd
say
i knew that like i think at least for me
uh
going to stanford is an acknowledgement
that entrepreneurship is something that
i'm very interested in
i did not expect to be going into
entrepreneurship
right away i thought okay i'll be
spending money
to go to school it's not necessarily the
best time to
start your own company let's get
established a bit in the industry
before deciding to start your own thing
but for me it ended up being a decision
well if not
now then then when now is the like
there's
there's no time like the presence to try
something out
um so that's where things have ended up
and
with the support of uh family and
friends have been able to do so
so far nice thank you for joining us
today
uh yaniv can you tell us a little bit
about what you're doing these days
of course hey everyone uh yaniv um
it's a very bittersweet uh moment for me
because i just graduated two weeks ago
uh so it's kind of like things farewell
to all your friends
uh so it's kind of difficult but also
very exciting
um at least we got a in-person
graduation which is amazing
so what i'm doing right now is working
on a startup in the food delivery space
that is backed by atomic
and actually what happened i was i did a
summer internship with them
and and once it was over basically they
added
you there and that's what i was
doing for that year for the i mean so
far for this year
hey you broke up for a little bit at the
end of there can you
uh recap uh the last thing that you said
please sure
i did a summer internship at atomic and
then they asked me to join as an eir
and that's what i've been doing for the
best year
and now moving on forward with that idea
nice and
entrepreneur in residence yes
yes exactly cool and then you're
probably going to know what i'm going to
ask you
did you know that you wanted that you
you're going to go into entrepreneurship
yeah so i started a company back in
israel uh five years before coming to
the gsp
um and that was always part of my goal
of coming here is to
kind of build a strong you know build
strong friendships in a community
globally that could help me you know
start something else and find what i'm
really passionate about and move forward
with it so
definitely yes nice and then claire
welcome welcome can you tell us a little
bit about what you're doing these days
thanks will
um it's great to be here uh i
am so i graduated in 2018
so i've been out for three years it has
flown by
um and i used to be
a high school math teacher and school
administrator and
came to school to sort of figure out how
to
ensure that our students were in
upwardly mobile jobs
in their mid-20s and stanford enabled me
to
pursue that through the social
innovation fellowship and
so i've been running an organization
called the arena
inc ever since which is a
non-profit that helps ensure that
educational institutions and industry
partners are connected
so we have a career navigation set of
tools for
young people ages 18 to 20 and then a
client services practice helping
institutions do this work in more depth
um and definitely still in building mode
so happy to share
all the learnings and then surprise
surprise
did you want to go into entrepreneurship
coming into the gst
um i think stanford the
the motto really uh encourages
um creativity and innovation and taking
kind of non-traditional paths so whether
i knew that
explicitly or not i sort of felt like
some of my experience was encouraging
that
but no i think i like cared about the
mission and was gonna kind of
support where i felt like i could
support and ended up building because i
was probably more stubborn and arrogant
than i like to admit
all right so from here i'm gonna go
ahead and stop
sharing screen this way we'll be able to
focus on
our panelists and so
speaking about like launching something
of your own
aaron maybe we can start with you what
was it like
launching during the pandemic like how
did you
tap into like the gsb resources or your
class
um to to help you along that way
yes very interesting time uh as you
might imagine a lot of uncertainty
uh as the world moves as it will move
forward
uh you know march this is my final
quarter at the gsb
uh i had been working with my
co-founders on prairie health at the
time
and so we went from in person to being
fully remote and we've been
solely remote ever since despite all
living in the bay area
as a result of having a year and a half
of or
a year and two thirds of the two years
at stanford there were
i was fortunate enough to be well
connected with a lot of different
resources
professors opportunities so
we rely heavily on the venture studio
for access to expertise
or to pitch competitions or access to
investors
relied heavily during that time on
introductions via the alumni network to
venture capitalists to raise our initial
round of financing as well as frankly
from classmates who
were involved with working at these at
these
vcs or had worked there previously
we just found that it didn't really
change anything
in our ability to have the conversations
we wanted to have and to
meet the people we wanted to meet thanks
to the network that stanford
had in front of us nice and then you
mentioned
design studio or venture studio can you
tell us a little bit more about
what that is um and if anybody else
has taken advantage of that resource
please feel free to chime in as well
yeah so i can share a bit uh it feels
like everywhere you look around stanford
there is an entrepreneur entrepreneurial
resource for you
uh whether or not you realize it is is
one thing i think like
there's more that exists and i was
probably even aware venture studio
is one of the flagship ones where it's a
interdisciplinary
program or you know cooperative almost
that's headquartered at the gsb at least
in terms of physical space where you
have physical space to work together
to build ideas they bring in experts
from
they bring in like lawyers they bring in
accountants they bring in
uh venture capitalists uh all sorts of
people to
help you uh incubate your ideas and get
off the ground
as well as connect you to pitch
opportunities
and help facilitate uh meeting
potential co-founders if you have an
idea or getting connected to an idea if
you
don't have one but you know what you
want to be an entrepreneur
so it's something that we've and even
even today there's an email list that's
very vibrant of people sharing resources
and building community that's
incredibly valuable when you're trying
to figure out
what do we do in this situation or does
anyone have experience here that's where
stanford has particularly shined and
helped us out
yeah if i could add a little bit to this
so concerning the email list
i found it to be super useful to me as
well so as a
very recent example a few weeks ago i
sent an email
on that listserv to express that i was
looking for
people were familiar with the car
insurance industry because i'm looking
into
a peer-to-peer car sharing platform that
i was hoping to work on potential early
summer
and there is an mba2 who saw the email
reached out to me
and we've been meeting ever since so
we've met about
seven times so far and we're actually
going to work together over the summer
that idea
so just wanted to give you a very
tangible example of how um
davinci studios lister has been actually
helpful
and while we're on the topic of
resources claire you mentioned the
center for social innovation can you
tell us a little bit about
um how you worked with them yeah
um the center for social innovation is
the sort of
hub of the social innovation and
nonprofit opportunities
at the gsb and um
they have a ton of different ways that
they like
to kind of have events at lunch and
bring in speakers and create more
exposure
to resources i think during the school
year you can do independent studies and
internships and sort of think about like
carving out space to test some of the
things that you maybe want to in
entrepreneurship
under stanford's umbrella and then i did
an internship at a non-profit
venture philanthropy fund over my summer
which was subsidized through the smith
program which enables
now that i'm an employer it's also
awesome um for
for getting interns but it enables you
to sort of take risks during your summer
and feel like you're making enough money
and you're part of the stanford
community and you can kind of
workshop your learnings or hypotheses or
whatever things you're kind of asking
throughout
um and then the social innovation
fellowship i think it's changing names
or they're sort of different
opportunities your second year or
afterwards
on how you might be able to pursue
this type of work full-time afterwards
but so there are like pockets of kind of
different things they're really great
advisors at the center
i found the like application process for
my fellowship
one of the most valuable things i did at
stanford just because
you have to kind of articulate your
business model and value prop
and i just you know hadn't done those
things in a formal sense previously
and get really really specific
one-on-one feedback
great office hours really great advisors
that continue to benefit me today
um so just sort of a wealth of resources
and if you're if you're kind of
wondering and wanting to explore while
you're there
kind of just going to their events to
start off
is a really helpful way to to get
started
yeah so while we're on the topic of kind
of resources and communities
uh yaniv i know you were a leader of one
of the communities can you tell us a
little bit about
about that sure of course so i was
trying to be as
involved that i can in entrepreneurship
within uh
the gym
oh you need you from the elections
you froze from one maybe if you go off
video for a moment
yes is that better yeah that's wonderful
thank you okay great so i was trying to
be
as involved as i can in the
entrepreneurial community
so i decided to become the president of
the
entrepreneurship club with four other
members
and essentially what we we've been doing
is you know bring
speakers who talk about their
entrepreneurial journey
we created brainstorm sessions and
kick off ideas with it with other
schools within stanford
we also partnered a lot with the venture
studio that jp
mentioned a little bit uh back
for example for example we had one
interesting
idea which was uh grad check which was
we we we connected uh current students
who were looking to follow an idea and
pursue entrepreneurship
with alumni who had resources and
connections and
and and and capital but not the time to
kind of like work on an idea actively
and that actually created new companies
um
you know with cross-class collaboration
and that was
really amazing and that was the reason
why you know
that was among the things that really
make
the gsb and stanford special yeah talk
about
impact by like connectivity and action
um so i'm gonna go ahead and jump to
this first
question that's in our q a box from
atapia just because i think
coming back to that gssb experience
there are some
pretty incredible moments during the
academic year
but then there's a summer between your
mba one and your mba two year
for some folks who might be going into
some more traditional routes that could
be the time that
they were doing internships or some
other
types of ways to explore those realms um
how might you
so maybe claire you talked a little bit
about the smith can you tell us
uh what you were doing during the summer
between your mba one and nba two year
and then we'll take uh we'll start with
you and then other folks can chime in
like what can folks do to advance
kind of their career aspirations in this
field
yeah so i guess first just to start like
if you
if you come you're gonna have two ish
years
to have this unique opportunity to not
be working full-time
and so more like before kind of these
formal opportunities they're also just
really informal ways to be like okay i
have more time and like brain space to
think about stuff than i
maybe ever will so meeting with
professors meeting with other students
creating more informal ways to like
workshop things or ask questions
i found really really useful and i spent
probably more time doing those things
than joining a bunch of clubs
and so it's sort of like figuring out
where you want to allocate your time
formally i during my summer so i had
previously
taught and noticed most of our
students were struggling with college
persistence and workforce connectedness
after high school and so i was sort of
like
not that there's a silver bullet but
that's a thing i wanna
i just i wanna understand like sort of
interventions in higher ed and in
workforce development what's happening
after high school
so i had some sort of questions that i
wanted to explore
and i also wanted to determine whether
i wanted to remain working in schools
closer to students or think about other
places of leverage
like funding or like policy
and so i had
kind of done a bit of research and found
an organization called the charter
school growth fund that supports public
schools across the country
and felt like that would help me
understand
like sort of functionally did i enjoy
thinking about working education kind of
it
from that like 30 000 foot up
place and also how would that also
give me a landscape view on like what
are some interesting school models
across the country how might i kind of
like
expose myself to different opportunities
and then smith
supported my ability to do that so
um sort of co-applied with our employer
with the employer um
and then was able to sort of like
reflect on my experience
with other folks who had done similar
internships afterwards
and then my second year i did a couple
independent studies
where i had sort of secondary sets of
questions and was like
before i pick a full-time job how do i
think about
learning in a more kind of focused way
and
again stanford really enabled my ability
to to do that
jp you're also doing something really
cool between uh and during the summer
can you tell us a little bit more about
that
sure happy too um so uh i guess what i'm
formally doing over this summer is the
voltage and fellowship but before
talking about that
i would like to tell you about what i've
been doing over the past few weeks
actually
so ever since school ended what i've
been doing is trying to
reflect on what i've learned and gotten
from the first year
so it's really been a lot of journaling
and a lot of
thinking about what i've gained what i
should focus on going forward
and also connecting with a lot of alumni
that i previously started
connecting with over the school year
just to make sure that i'm
thinking of the next steps and the best
way possible
so for me i've been in somewhat of a
dilemma
because whenever i came here to the gsd
i was very adamant on working on
something that can be
impactful and places like haiti my home
country
and what i found is that over the course
of the year i've been
working on different ideas and little by
little i felt like i've been pivoting
away from
anything that could work in those
markets so
that's where my dilemma came i was
wondering if i was being true to my
mission into my goal
so essentially what i've been doing over
the past few weeks is really reflecting
on what i want to do for the summer and
for my second year of the mba
to make sure that i'm actually doing
something that can make me feel
fulfilled
so it's been a lot of reflecting and
whatnot but what i will be doing
starting july
is the voltage and fellowship where
essentially we're giving funding
to explore a business idea or can even
be a space
so it's a lot of customer discovery
interviews which means
getting out the door speaking to people
might be your potential customers making
sure that there's
a need and that there's also
people willing to pay for whatever
service that you might be offering to
make sure that you have something that
may be viable
and the hope is that sec your second
year of the nba
and going forward you could actually
start building that idea of the ground
so i'm really looking forward to it but
i just want to make sure that before i
start
i nailed down at least the industry that
i want to focus on because of
my concerns and i explained to you
currency nice
um so jp was talking about how how to
focus his mba two year so maybe aaron or
you know can any advice for him courses
electives
experiences that might be really helpful
for jp to think about
sure um i learned that
everyone is just super committed to your
success
whether it's amazing professors who are
just
completely open to connect you to anyone
they can
to listen to you to help you think
through
you know i i took for example a class
called product launch with professor
jonathan lev
i think who i think is really amazing
it's just been so helpful
and there's so many other professors and
even your peers
your classmates everyone's just so
committed to helping each other out
it's just magical and that's what really
makes the gsp what it is so
just reaching out to people you have
like like everything is reachable here
and it's just
talking to people and learning more
throughout you know
those discussions that that for me was
invaluable
yeah yeah i get actually get a lot of
questions about like
how accessible are the faculty can you
talk a little bit more about like how do
you reach out do you have to take their
class
what are some of the settings that
you're able to engage with them
sure um so i'm actually shocked
now after two years by how accessible
they are
it seems far away because they're so
busy they're professors they're
investors they have so much going on
but then you you you know you reach out
whether it's by phone on campus via
email like
you're you know i'm thinking about
pivoting or i'm thinking about
uh applying to this job and i was
wondering if you have a couple minutes
to grab coffee and talk about it and
and the answer is always yes and
they will sit down with you and you know
and
just be super helpful it's like once
you're here and once you're part of the
community
they just want you to reach out and they
want to be helpful and it's kind of like
maybe it's kind of like a win-win i
guess at some point but it's just
really amazing like i don't have any
other words to it
nice erin any tips for nba two-year
yes uh definitely although every
everyone's mba 2 year is going to look
different that's part of what's great
about stanford
uh when thinking about entrepreneurship
it does there is a big trade-off you
have to consider about
when and how early you want to be
working on your company
so on my end i started working on uh
prairie health at uh in
the winter of uh my second year
so two thirds of the way support during
my second year
so there's a very uh there's a very
strong trade-off in terms of
the amount of time you work on your new
company which you you think
you think and hope will be the next big
thing or
versus enjoying your time at stanford
taking advantage of other classes you
might not otherwise
take uh so for me i my second year was
full of classes that were directly
relevant to
uh my actual company that i was working
on on the side
which i found to be very useful in that
nothing there fewer things are in the
abstract were like oh what if we were
thinking about this how would we
approach it it's actually i am thinking
about this
how do you think i should approach this
and it helps you engage with the
material
it helps me engage with the material
much more so my second year i took
a course on mental health innovation
that was offered
across the street across the street as
they as they say
i took a class on health care leadership
i took a class on
soft skills interpersonal dynamics i
think through how do i
manage difficult conversations as i come
up in the context of entrepreneurial
experiences
things like that that really helped uh i
was able to
take courses through this specific
learnings which was
prairie health yeah and so um i'm gonna
jump into sabrina's question here i'm
talking about
how to incubate incubate ideas what are
some of the resources that uh
gsb offered so i know aaron you just
mentioned
launching um kind of and working on it
during your mba two year were there any
other resources
folks you turned to during that process
yes so as with anything at
stanford it does feel like there are
opportunities around the corner and they
happen uh all the time organically
one of the best things about stanford is
that every or most people have at the
back of their minds
an interest in entrepreneurship so
everyone is excited to talk about new
ideas
sing like so you often just hear about
ideas and
think through opportunities because of
your classmates
experiences and their backgrounds some
of the ways in which the diversity of
backgrounds really plays as an advantage
but how i actually got connected to my
now co-founders is there is as simple as
a spreadsheet
of people like a form that people filled
out to say i have an idea i'm looking
for co-founders
i'm i'm looking to get connected to a
startup and then from there coffee chats
happen
so uh i met you know my one of my
co-founders
over coffee six months before we decided
to start working together and
kept in touch uh just that
at the gsb would meet every couple
months see how things were going
get more excited about what we could be
building together
and the rest is history in some ways
nice um talking about co-founders and
finding partners to
like launch ideas with does anybody else
have any um
kind of experiences with how you found
people to assist you in this journey
well i would say another one is by
taking some of the entrepreneurship
classes that are gsb offers
so for example i enrolled in launchpad
in my second quarter of gsb
um and that can also give some insight
into the previous question as well about
the incubation of ideas
so in order to apply for that class it's
a very experiential
learning class meaning it's super
hands-on so you have to apply as a team
and finding team members work with me
was actually
pretty easy so first of all there was a
platform
allowing not only jsb students but
stanford students at large to find each
other based on interest so essentially
say hey i'm interested in that field or
industry and i want to take this class
if you're interested reach out to me and
that was
the way that i approached it but also
paying attention to what people are
interested in
so a few people ended up being my
teammates were people that i had
conversations with previously and i
remembered
what they were passionate about what
their skill sets were and i just reached
out and said hey
i'm gonna take me launchpad would you be
interested in taking it with me
and that was a very easy way to actually
get into get a team on board
now when it comes to that actual class
uh it's been
extremely valuable to me it's really a
class that teaches you how to
go by and validate whether or not an
idea has business potential
by doing a lot of customer discovery
interviews so
the class expected us to put in about
20 hours of work a week per person so
you really have to take it seriously but
you get so much out of it as well
and it teaches you the right types of
questions to ask potential customers to
ask people in the industry
the right ways to go by testing
hypotheses
and it's really a way for you to save a
lot of time as you experience
this idea because you can quickly
determine whether or not it's worth
continuing or not
instead of spending so much time and
resources into something that may not
actually have so much potential
and to give you a interesting anecdote
so right after taking that class it was
spring break
i felt so encouraged
that i actually spent part of my spring
break going out and interviewing
a number of retailers uh just because i
felt like
i had a strong framework in place and i
was
not shy about you know talking to
potential customers so i literally spoke
to
about 90 uh retailers just going
door-to-door
talking to them about what their needs
were what what difficulties that they
were facing in
see if i could
whether or not a business has potential
even before i put in too much resources
into it
yeah it says something when there's a
class that gets you to spend your entire
spring break um validating a business
idea
or something that you're that you really
care about um speaking about
things that you care about claire um as
you
were working with the arena were there
any like seminal moments
aha um experiences or
like moments at the gsb that
have shaped do you think that shape the
way that you operate as a kind of a
leader in the field
that's a good question um
yes i
i want to think about that
um actually so i think one of the
biggest things i learned with the
biggest things i have learned since
being at school um
was sort of like how much i came into
school with
um and and like certain
moments during the gsb like validated
that i think i think
at first i was sort of like i need to
have i need to gain some financial
fluency
build some business chops to be taken
seriously like my
work builds trust with some people but
not all
and if i want to start an organization i
need to
be able to to kind of demand more
for and from others um
and and so i felt actually like in the
maybe a long way of answering your
question but like in the beginning i
felt sort of insecure
that you know i hadn't learned certain
things in finance and accounting that a
lot of my peers had
um and built some fluency but i think
actually the second year where a lot
more of the classes like aaron mentioned
are electives around eq
and management brought to the surface a
lot of experiences that i had come in
with that
were going to be really useful and
that those like small moments in touchy
feely or in
other courses where you're role playing
or you're like
kind of doing case studies or managing
different challenges live
um stamped for me that like i
had built up some of those skills
previously and got to practice them
again during school and then reminded
again
since that those are um
really useful that like at the end of
the day they're sort of
like what we're doing which is about
supporting young people and bringing
together schools and employers
um but at the end of the day it's about
like
people on my team and the students that
we work with and the employers that we
work with and it's about kind of
emotions and connections and motivation
and
that sort of feels true above all else
and so i think
those moments in classes that reminded
me of what i had built before
and like what matters at the end of the
day i think continue to
like those are the things that keep me
up at night um
and and felt like a helpful couple years
where i was
sort of reminded of that and i'm still
yeah so
aaron similar questions for you like
leading
prairie health were there any moments
kind of
pivotal moments where you're just like
something you learn that you carry
and continue to apply today
yeah similarly hard question uh
as it should be i'd say
like one there's a class called
entrepreneurial finance
taught by rob siegel that's highly rated
for good reason
it teaches you all about the nuance of
working with venture capitalists what
are all the different
tools and mechanisms that you have to
negotiate this thing that
i had never seen before in terms of a
term sheet
so that was immensely helpful and will
continue to be helpful as we
raise additional funding moving forward
so that's one thing that
uh in terms of practical skills that i
would not have taken otherwise if i
hadn't been both interested in
entrepreneurship and at the gsb
i would be reading blog posts and being
very confused
uh otherwise i'd say the interpersonal
dynamics
class or affectionately called touchy
feely
is always or
for me it was an incredibly profound
experience and a sentiment shared by
many of my classmates as well where it
dissects how do you interact with the
group
what are your what are the things that
motivate you how do you
motivate and influence others and
there's a lot of self-reflection that is
i think incredibly important as a leader
to be able to figure out what are the
people that who
report to you what what do they care
about how do you how do you support
their goals and how do you
make sure that you are working together
constructively rather than destructively
so that's something that i draw and say
when
when managing people and frankly
interacting with other members of my
team
and also personal relationships as well
because interpersonal dynamics is is
life in many ways
yaniv this question i'm gonna start with
you you
worked in you created you had a venture
before coming to the gsb
and so this is coming from victor um
about like
he's heard that you don't really need an
mba to successfully launch a startup
venture
um so what would your response be to
folks who say that
and how did the gsb prepare you for
entrepreneurship or
what else did you get from the
experience that you might not have
otherwise
yeah so let me turn off the video so we
don't uh create lags here but
basically very good question i actually
added
this discussion with uh five or ten
classmates
and and basically what i feel when i
when i'm you know reflecting back on
these two years and
how i changed um first of all your
perspective you just
think bigger you aspire higher
whether it's the people around you that
every single one of them
is amazing and interesting whether it's
the speakers that are so inspiring
whether it's vcs who are constantly
scouting for
people at the gsp want to start ideas
and just look to invest capital in them
all these things just push you forward
in a way that you know i look at myself
two years ago and i'm like
it's not the same thing you know it's
the strong i don't want to call it
network it's the strong friendships that
you've created these are friends for
life
they will be there for you wherever you
are in the world it's it's
the it's it's the connections and the
relationship with the professors
and what they've taught you that you'll
take forward and you'll just
you'll come out another a better person
and
a more you know you can take a company
from zero to
one but or from zero to a hundred but
this will just allow you to
to to expand your horizon and to go to
places you couldn't otherwise at least
that's what i feel when i think about my
experience
and you know and myself right now
thank you anybody else from the group
how would you respond or like what are
your thoughts on
uh on the statement like why get an mba
you could do you could do a startup or
have a venture without one
yeah i'm happy to respond to this one as
well so i think for me
um a lot of what you said resonated
strongly
but in addition i think getting an mb is
more about
starting a company it's also about
personal growth and personal development
so for me for example one of my goals
was to really work on my communication
skills
over the next few years at the gsb so
i've been trying to really make the most
out of it so to give you some examples
i've been meeting with my communications
coach one-on-one
literally on a weekly basis on top of
that i've taken
electives communications related i've
taken a class called essential strategic
communication which has been
super helpful to me i was lucky enough
to
have been able to do what's called a low
keynote so it's up for some context dual
keynote is essentially
similar to a ted talk but for the gsb
you can literally come up with
any topic that you're interested or
passionate about
write a talk about it and deliver it but
the nice thing is
you have a coach who works with you as
you're crafting
your story and you also have that same
coach work with you as working under
delivery as well
so all of that has been super invaluable
to me
and i could not think of a better place
to work on them
than here at ugsb and on top of that
it's also a nice
time those two years to reflect on what
my values are
um to reflect on what i wanna
or how i wanna come come by as a leader
so be exposed to different leadership
styles and
fine-tune my own leadership skills to
something that i'm very comfortable with
and that feels authentic to me so i can
make the most of my potential as a
leader as well in the future
so i would say the soft skills are also
an extremely important component of
getting an mba out of gsb um and
even though the entrepreneurial aspect
is extremely strong um those areas are
also
well known and extremely important as
well to be a successful meeting in the
future
nice um so shameless plug
low keynotes are available like many of
them are recorded and they're posted on
the stanford gsb
youtube site uh so i would definitely
recommend checking out some of the
different things that like
spark passion and life in our students
um there's some
really awesome talks there so definitely
check that out
um claire i saw you popped off of uh
mute so
i i if we want to move on though i'm
happy to oh no
please perfect i was just gonna say in
terms of the do you need an mba
like no you don't need an mba you can
hack your way into entrepreneurship and
i think you probably are a scrappier
leader if you have had to bootstrap
things
um but i like
it was a huge privilege to be able to
to earn an mba and i think in its
and it's very like on the low end
it's a really strong insurance plan like
you have uh you know you have the degree
that's a signal
you also have all of the relationships
the that everybody has mentioned both
with your classmates with professors
with practitioners
um and opportunity begets opportunity so
it almost feels like
i sort of felt like
the people i know and what i'm able to
do because of this
experience make me feel even more
emboldened
to try new things and take risks because
not everybody has this opportunity
um like if you if you have a mission and
you have a pain point
that you want to solve and you want to
pursue entrepreneurship like you will
make that work regardless of whether you
have
those letters on your transcript but i
think the like
series of opportunities that it opens up
and people that it opens up continue to
benefit me um years out and will
um and so of course like it's not it's
not critical but
i you definitely won't regret going
and um both the
the time to reflect and re-center
and make a more conscious decision about
where you want your career trajectory to
go
and all the people to kind of help you
do that i think are really invaluable
during the two years as
folks on the panel are mentioning and
then kind of afterwards with the
relationships and the network that
that follow you aaron um would you
anything to contribute from uh ken where
you're sitting now that you've
started a firm and are like working on
growing it
yeah i'd echo everyone else for me the
decision was
i can do all these things individually i
can build a network i can move from
technology to healthcare technology i
can
uh quit my job and do all these things
but
i think to clara's point it there is
there is so much that you can
do with an mba so many things that you
haven't thought about that ideas you get
exposed to
and frankly the the idea of building
my network to exploring new ideas
doing that all that individually was
just not going to happen while working a
full-time job
so the the stanford mba
gave this opportunity to
pursue professional and personal
development
uh to jp's point to explore ideas within
the industry how can i make an impact on
something that i care
passionately about so that was
the culmination of why i eventually
decided to pursue an mba although it
i was going back and forth for a long
time and do not regret making the
decision to go
nice so um 4 45
i want to make sure that we're able to
spend a little bit of time on an
area that i really love like selfishly
as an admissions officer
the admissions process i know as folks
are thinking about
uh career opportunities in
entrepreneurship there's also that stuff
of okay
approaching business school like what
are some things to think about
tips best practices um so as
you were approaching the mba and you
were applying i know aaron you just
mentioned that you were
you weren't sure at first did i get that
correct so
when you were filling out your
application like how did you approach
like
specificity versus like purpose like how
did you talk about your interests in the
application
yeah so uh for my
for my application i ended up writing at
least for the essay which is the most
salient part for me and probably for
many of you listening you're like
how the heck do i encapsulate my entire
life and purpose of being into a single
question uh very stressful so
thanks for that
so it was but frankly it is
it does epitomize the stanford culture
in many ways it's full of
self-reflection
introspection a figure like how do i
want to be spending my time
for me i ended up writing about uh
my passion to pursue the intersection of
technology and neurological disorders
i to be honest i did not expect fully to
be actually doing that
now that i'm you know working my company
uh
focusing on mental health but uh
i spent by far the most amount of time
on my essay
to try to come and try to come to
like the distillation of why why is it
that i'm pursuing an mba and why is this
the right next step for me
and that was helpful regardless of
whether i actually applied but
obviously i was able to get in so thank
goodness for
yeah it sounds like the focus rather
than
writing to get in you were writing to
understand kind of your
inner direction motivations the things
that were driving you tonight
um for anybody else on the panel did was
that a similar
kind of like thing that you experienced
or process um yeah so
i i really uh what aaron
really resonates with me i felt the same
way i applied to
you know at least four or five schools
and that question is so different
and it requires you to sit down for
weeks and think about what is important
to you and you come out
a different person in the end and i know
maybe it sounds a bit cliche
but but it's true because you you don't
get at least i
never got to ask myself that question
and then suddenly
you're confronted with it and it just
says a lot about the school you know
asking that type of question
and it just and pointing back to the
school you know
that emphasis on on soft skills on
community
on you know we have something called
talk
which is basically every every week
someone
else like another person from our class
comes and tells us
his life story and his motivation and
what is important to him and it kind of
similarly to the to to to that say
really kind of like you go
a bit deeper one layer deeper here and
that's what makes this place so unique
so
i totally agree aaron nice
all right so one question and this one's
going to go around to everyone here
for anybody who's out there are there
any tips
best practices advice that you might be
able to give
whether it is on the application process
things to think about as you are in the
midst of your mba
or kind of as you're launching into your
career in
entrepreneurship so give folks a moment
to think that through that's a
really big question with a lot of
potential ways to go um
and any of your wisdom pearls of wisdom
would be much appreciated so whenever
someone's ready feel free to jump on and
get us kicked off
i need to go first on this one uh so
let's say for me
make it a habit to reflect sit down
reflect
journal as much as you can because it's
a practice that not only helped me as i
was applying to the gsb
because in order to answer that question
what matters most to you and why
i really had to sit down and think of
different episodes in my life
that were impactful to me and try to
see if they were coming themes so being
able to do that exercise was extremely
valuable
but then also before i started my first
year out of jsb
i actually spent one week by myself i
went to colorado
um and i spent that entire time trying
to reflect on ways i wanted to approach
my first year of the mba
and i found out to be extremely valuable
when i came here
even though it wasn't a
framework that i stuck to entirely at
least i had
a guiding post i knew what was important
to me so i knew what opportunities to
apply to
i knew what not to pay as much attention
to because the gsb throws so much at you
that if you don't take that time to
reflect you just might
drown a little bit um and it's been
useful to me as well as i kept going
through the year so i've made it a habit
to journal as often as i could
to make sure i'm not wasting my time on
gsb because time flies so fast
so if you don't really take the time to
reflect it's almost like
you're not making the most of the
experience and most recently as i've
been trying to decide
on what to focus on over the summer and
for my second year
of the of the mba program reflection has
given me so much peace of mind because
i've been able to identify things that
really matter to me
um and that's been super gratifying
thank you
yeah i can go ahead um although i'm not
part of the admissions uh committee
i had some conversation with we had
dinner me and my husband with kirsten
moss
and what i understood i think
i think this is important to kind of
like note uh when you apply
is that it's really important to just be
genuine and just be yourself because
when you're
when you're trying to be someone else it
just doesn't add up
people can sense it but when you just
you know
reflect on what's important to you you
put it down on paper
and everything kind of like matches and
works together and your passion goes
through
you know the paper in in every aspect of
your application
that's what makes a winning application
and and i've seen it with so many of my
classmates and friends
um so that's my number one tip
thank you
aaron or claire
go for it
okay uh let's see so i already talked a
bit about the essay so what i'd say
is if you if you are accepted
and joined don't underestimate the power
of the stanford.edu
email address something that
you have an incredible unique and time
limited opportunity
to be a student if if you are
erin and you're asking like the day
before you get that email address and
you send an email to somebody else
they may not respond to you but you can
use the stanford email.e
or the edu email address to have
conversations
even before you're an officially a
student
to connect with members of the alumni
community so
to get you know internships if you want
to try out something new even before you
start classes
some that people do not not for me but
uh is an opportunity so
that that tool alone opens so many doors
uh because you have an opportunity to
ask questions to learn and people want
to support you in that
especially alumni thank you and claire
taking us home the email address that's
very true um i
i think it's been already said i think
it's like time to reflect and just
like come to the application process and
the essay and the experience like
kind of grounded in yourself and what
you want from it like i think maybe
there's a tendency
with the application process to try to
sell this grand vision or like the sort
of best version of yourself but i think
taking the kind of what matters to your
question to its
most authentic and simplest form for you
um
will just like set you up for
the experience a little bit better too
and i think
then going into it thinking about you
know there are so many different
opportunities
and you might feel the need to do
everything but get very little out of
everything if you do that and so
spending
time thinking about like what are you
trying to learn and
what do you bring into the experience to
make more
selective choices i found really really
useful
thank you jp a new error and claire
thank you
so much for joining us today i have
one more quick slide to share with folks
if you haven't done so already i
encourage you
uh to go on to mystanford.mba
create that dashboard to help feed some
of the things that you might be
interested in learning more
join us throughout the summer we're
gonna have a ton more events
with some new cool ones that we're gonna
be launching in the next few months so
you'll see
some advertisements about that from us
um until then thank you
so much for joining us as well wherever
in the world you are
and if i can summarize any of the advice
given today
uh that i would extra double tap is you
be
you so thank you so much and i hope to
see you all again soon